fox news just celebrated 20 years at
number one the first cable news channel
in history to hit that landmark it's
been an honor and a privilege to crush
cnn and msnbc especially cnn and the
ratings over the years but it's a team
effort as they say over at pbs we
couldn't do this without viewers like
you
now a lot of you who turn in are
conservatives independents and we
appreciate you but there's another
demographic who apparently can't get
enough of fox
democrats
and i'm not just talking about my own
mom now i didn't believe this either but
we've seen the data
liberals love fox news now they might
not admit it to their friends but
they're watching us and they're watching
us a lot more than they're watching cnn
and msnbc
the latest numbers from nielsen show in
october fox commanded 42 percent of
democrat viewers between 25 and 54.
while cnn only had 33 in msnbc a measly
25
those numbers are pretty impressive what
do they mean
maybe we're not so different you and i
so democrats your secret's out and
that's okay
we know you're watching and we're here
for you and we want to hear from you
so text me numbers right here at the
bottom of the screen and we're going to
chat this time tomorrow hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else